arenas eastern bullet arena
let's see who's in the mix here
they're five minutes in
i may be going back to uh
some viewer games i'm not sure never get
to all of them
but they've been fun
all right
it's a bullet chests
no from position
no early imbalance
what a boring start position
all right
it's tough to liberate that bishop
maybe impossible
uh it was unnecessary to jump with the
knight
he's a good
good piece right where he's at nice
controller
they're in trouble because they're the
queen is opposite i have this kind of
stuff
remove the knight
and
i'm going to say let's be all right with
i almost got back rank mated
let's go with queen d4 or queen here
this knight kills the bishop
so
yeah that to be
very careful
did a good job of getting that bishop
out and about though let's say
got this covered
bishop's really good though
okay
they're down on time
221 in there
let us see my game is better thank you
for the tier one sub
that's a new name i don't recall seeing
my game is better in the chat
thank you for that sub
chess rastami
next opponent
okay this this is usually going to be
asking for trouble bishop a3
bishop f5 was probably a better
initial deployment of my bishop
that makes possible the
the win of an exchange
sets that kind of stuff up
bishop d3 okay i guess
to be careful
oh
there's some sacrifice
going on here maybe
on this twice
take their night with chuck
it's covered
i don't know if i want to win that pawn
guard my seventh
thinking i do want to win that pawn
stop the rook from getting there
okay
i'd like to have one rook off
oh they're in a pickle hitting a lot of
stuff take the bishop with check
it's a full rook
watch out for stalemate
slow down there for a second
okay
under 50.
hello brew move
thank you arizona glad you're enjoying
the streams and the videos
be careful i might put you right to
sleep
cpt was saying earlier i put them to
sleep
they fell asleep
before i got to their challenge
past stream
i think it's sensible to control that b5
square
b2 i don't even think i'm threatening
something in g2
possibly
clean h5
oh they're threatening me
threatening me again
or at least
you're ready to
scare me a little bit
this and keep the bishop defended here's
always going to be met with that
and we got forks
uh i was too early with that
yeah night there is gonna be good
centralize the queen
careful now
and what next
get a g3
f2
f2 for me
whoo that was a fast pairing
all right we're in 27th
i'll go queen side
now that i have a half open file to work
with
ooh okay
stop knight a3 if i can
knight b4 might have been a move
double rooks my knight on f3 could do
something
something else
okay
possible for
stopping that
their night is the glue
let's get rid of the glue
no i'm really not sure how to break down
this position
if this i think i need to stay put
my knight
okay that one
i have this pawn
my queen's hungry
all right they didn't have any time
there
almost on page one
i've played this guy a bunch
let's see
space
got the space
i was supposed to stop that
okay
jump in here
straight my pawns out
i like my position
knight on f5
okay
um
my knight needs to do something else
all right
where does my night belong
um
prove my king
okay finally have to go for this break
them in that pin
might be winning now
getting mated
that would have been bad man really bad
i had plenty of time
why was i playing so fast there
i could have slowed down a little bit
for a second
that little pond
they're promoting
with check
they had the main one maybe they
mouselipped because they were moving
their queen along that file
lucky
i could take care now
connected passer
they take here
we got this kind of stuff
knight takes here we have that
maybe other
other moves too
babysit everything
watch out for bishop f5
okay with the exchange
you got two pawns now
uh
let's give a check for starters
i'll take
oh
one pawn
advantage should be enough in these
endings
we got a second
just in case
all right i think that's putting me on
page one
320 in there
okay
41 minutes left
okay
i maybe could have grabbed that bishop
i like my knight on c5 better than the
bishop as of now
knight into that d4 squares
as soon as that knight moves
i think knight f5 is the way
okay that's a good move
let's glue the knight in there
okay with giving up a pawn
i'd have a huge grip over the dark
squares
g5 i could get that in
be wonderful
i don't mind them taking this this
knight is
a really good piece i'll i'll hang oh
i'm giving up this pun
i missed that one
maybe i should simply take
uh
have a check
hmm
i don't like my queen oh
i guess we could try this i'm on b2
check
oh move move move
activity
careful
time time time
okay
anon
thank you for the anonymous donation
tko
thank you for the prime resub two months
easy hill can for the tier one
resub seven in a row
all right
should focus on this
one meet f5 with e5
you can do this
king nf6 in an ending
oh night there i'm losing a pawn
hmm
this is a problem my king
i don't know if i like my king
all right hang on
oh i have a good move
rook f2 i have this
can't be caught
i lucked out there
it hasn't changed same situation
i could have took the rook with check
first and then recaptured
no stalemates
okay
we got 28 liangelo balls in first
bicov misha
second sultan
next up
i haven't seen kettled yet i didn't play
g3
usually only ch5 after uh
g3 is in there
okay
my sights
set on this square
flush the knight away
earn a pin
player feels like they're
much stronger than their rating
not sure why i just did that
how long have i been on that one
that was a free piece for a bit
thinking
um
i want to get the queens off
okay i have that
why did i just pause for so long right
there oh i have this as me
okay
check yourself 22. thanks for the tier
one resub 53 months
hit him with the h2 you said anand thank
you for the five dollar donation same
person i'm guessing you had a brain
cramp
typed what you're thinking instead of
the message thanks for all the content
over the years you are awesome
thank you also
butt face
make brain lag
thank you for the prime resub three
months now
all right
ah this is probably not the way
probably not the way see
okay the c pawn's gonna
okay no knight a5 that's this knight
can have a tough tough time
i'm up a pawn
let's hang on to it for a little bit
knight on this square should be pretty
juicy
nothing happening on the long diagonal
bishop on e3
let's give this check
that's a thread i got a couple pins
i thought the knight was throwing my
bishop that's why i moved it just then
how do i get rid of that uh
let's get out of pins
i have much time
break down the dark squares that's
that's the way
oh i didn't want i want to give this
check first
now they have to go into a self pin
[Music]
okay
warrior 01 thank you for the 50 bits
could i play king's game but look at
suggestions here king's gambit i guess
immortal evergreen thank you for the
prime sub all right guess the king
king's gamut's gonna have to wait
that's far from my bread and butter
king's gambit
that's for sure
i'm gonna go queenside
i'm already regretting my uh
decision to go
queenside let's see
get an open g file
you're still in a pin
let's get out of this night move with
check
scary
we're both pawn storming each other
that's probably the one to go with the
one that creates tension
um
i guess we hang on to the night
gotta defend there
um i could take here though my queen i
have extra defense here
it's a mess
this pond's pinned
guard my back rank
time
time was on my side
grand prix attack
okay oh i didn't realize i'm in first
there
still a half hour to go
um
[Music]
let's be a developer
all right i feel like i have uh
lost a tempo
along the way here
okay
work on c8
2-1 majority
what should i be doing with my pawns on
the king's side dark squares i guess
ideally
to get some space
fix that guy
or create a new
path
i want to stop night here
okay my rook is being a bug
uh
pins for a moment
prove my king
feels like i'm close to getting mated if
i go there
ah
time time time
who
barely barely barely
okay
do i still hold my breath during the
bullet tournaments
um
yeah i probably find myself just you
know
it's not a full hold my breath but like
i i feel like i'm not breathing normally
let's say
yeah that that still
definitely is a thing
towards the center okay that was their
big big bishop they gave me their
dark squares
i'll take and then focus on this e5
square these guys are under control oh
actually that guy could be a nuisance
let's control the knight
it's gonna be my best piece right here
okay i have to worry about the oh
bishop g5 gets the queenie
i thought instead of uh
instead of a4 maybe bishop a4
angelo ball
the angelo ball
no b5
a b5 can be played i should have played
a5
or maybe not
all right
a pressure here i think this is winning
winning the d6 pawn and it should
collapse
still on d6
i'll take here and get out of this
tension
p7 throw my bishop
let's go to a cozy square
push this pawn queen d5
you get that f5
i was on this too
okay that's me
could have captured on f7 and then went
to e8
24 minutes left
dimirio again
oh i haven't been trying for the king's
gambit
that'll be my first loss i'm so
focused on
d4 by default
the forks
okay they resigned
yes you're pointing it out i see there
f7 definitely was hanging
go with the pawn
oh get down double
we'll work on a structural deficiency i
guess i want to keep one rook on
to have some winning chances i don't
want to straighten their pawns out
get away
no support points
and i guess we try for
c5 from here
or this this could be because now i
could shoot for b4
i have these potential targets
let me improve my king first
[Music]
okay now we'll go for it
gotta get the break in
bishop beats bishop g3 can be a move
so there was benefit after all with
putting that pawn on h5 i didn't
appreciate it
at the time
or k2
sneakiness
bishop might be cooked soon
i've made in a couple
actually bishop here doesn't solve it i
get to take
oh they're on a
i'm on the rook i was on the rook there
i didn't see it
okay
no rooks
that feels like it's very close that was
a mouse slip it feels like it's very
close to
draw land
but with rooks
different story
i'll look to limit the mobility of the
bishop on b7
okay
king side action
guess i'll grab that
oh i'm on the queen there
okay he resigned
20 left
just shy of 500 in here
okay
oh this was this uh
that yeah that one where i had to go
with some
fancy b4 pawn sacrifice to make a break
hmm
um
i guess here
knight right here i'd love to get that
in there
being annoying
should have went too
um okay so they're allowing me to
i guess we'll take now
hmm
am i getting that pawn something
oh
there i wasn't holding my breath that
was just a
so focused barely breathing
17 remain
zion
pure in heart
long time it i feel it feels like it's
been over a year
since we've played
it feels like it's been a while
all right let's get rid of that pesky
pawn
okay
give me a break
in betweener
and this
oh they missed that one i think
did they
let's harass the rook first
okay
uh i guess we take
i had that pond
i missed that i had that pawn
whoa
and try and shut down that queen
okay now can we trade
okay
good game zion
udab
the number two guy
some gambit
i'm not gonna bite
all right i have the bishop pair
i'm satisfied
and we get the true bishop pair
the true bishop pair is on the scene
stop this maneuver
look for an a4 break the bishops do a
good job of stopping all entry points
some space here
now that the knight is left we go here
be careful they're dark squares okay so
let's try that first
rook there we're gonna have me oh they
have an entry point now
killer bees are on the scene
um i could take here with check
and then take here and be on the rook
feels like i could have done a little
better there
i should be up it feels like more than
the exchange but that should do the
trick
all right 13 left
oh
5 18 in here
let's see
b
three move one
okay
work on that i guess we take it upon
i don't like having to go into
babysitter mode
that's where we're at
oh boy swiss cheese incoming
all right i have to give up my my a pawn
and shoo this knight away
i'm on the rook
stop their knight from getting here
negate their bishop
bound to kill me
start pushing
oh that's a free pawn
hmm
ah the long distance move i couldn't
pull it off
oh man my rook had to travel too many
squares to take a rook
okay
that pressure that they had on my b-pawn
must have shaved off a
few seconds for my clock at least
so behind
okey dokey
you're still in the pin
on d6
on the rook
oh i'm in this
pickle
no b4 oh they had b4 there
let's hang on to the e pawn
i think they should try f5
rick f2 to negate anything on the second
rank
i can run
to f4
behind
and then push
mate threat
mate threat
no time
okay constant
oh that's unusual
take with the knight
the lead in development
oh i should watch out bishop there that
would have been a bad pre-move
um
let me get the roof oh no
getting mate huh
did not realize i was gonna be quick to
grab the rook there
four more games maybe we'll count
jclp
i should have played e3
bishop g6 now
i have this as a convenient reply and i
really don't want to open up the h file
got to get this break in
right here
watch over the e5 square
let's try this f5
i'm on f7
ooh dark squares
let's go like this
open up the f file
um
rook up and over
looks weird i don't want to see the c5
break though
try and reposition my bishop stop bishop
a5 for the moment
oh they're on that
whoops
target f7 actually queen on f3
should cause some inconvenience
i'm on this
i missed that
queen is a little
like she's in a box over there
clean right here
got the discovered check
coming up
all right back to tournament five and
change
i think i'm gonna get paired with zion
just finished
zion it is
smith mora gambit
i'm probably asking for trouble having
my queen on d6 here
i have check
castles i don't know how annoying that
would be
okay
had to be timely there
i am worse
oh really
i'm gonna i'm gonna believe it
and i believe that that one is working
if i take it now
weaseling out
i don't want more files to open
threatening meat
that was
scary
the greek gift
i don't know could i have captured that
i don't think so
a g5 queen h5
klingsman
so be the last one that counts for the
tournament i imagine
poison pond there
let's castle before it's too late
all right let's run
probably not a good oh i have this
covered
my bishop
is there
i'm on the rook and this pawn
um
let's go here
oh
giving up my a pawn really shouldn't
okay
i doubt this next one's going to count
try to end on a good note
minute left
again let's try the french
bishop b5
bishop b4
a bit of an oddball
approach i'm taking here
i think it's good though
it can be
why am i giving that up
bishop on g5 can be excellent
can
knight on c4 as well
bishop here first maybe was better
rolling the dice somewhat
made them think at least
knight h3 and then breaking
breaking this down
time i'm busted there
pretty sure in the end okay
i'm back to tournament land
good
games all
you